I'm going to break this down into like said
those categoriesLet's create our first
function here.
And this is just going to be called hero
attack
For the most part we kind of relaxed it had
this sectioned off for this
So from here let's actually take all this
and I'm just going to control XAnd add it
down to my hero attack.
Whoops I caught a little bit of the hero
attack there myself and then awesome we get
that in there so the cool thing now
Is I can actually call that hero attack
function within my tag
Even though none of this code exists up
inside this function attack anymore
When we go to our console
We will see the same functionality work
though we can actually see the villains
Health going down every time we attack
Let me actually not bringing the accounts I
didSo you're at the application whenever I
click attack we can actually still see the
villain's.
health is indeed still going down even
though we're not calling it within that
first function
So let's do the same exact thingFor our
villain.
So we'll just call this one the same thing
we'll just make it simple we'll say villain
attack
Let's go to that section villain and we're
going to go all the way downUntil we hit
that.
Essentially what we like to call a draw
function
So after our hero attack will thenCall our
villain attack.
And we can go ahead and clean this up so you
could actually usually just get rid of your
console logs once you know they work
Waiting for this instance I'm going to keep
them in there for a referencing purposes
So now we actually have just these last
drawls
And I'm just going to call this one draw
health
Because it's just going to draw all the
health of the hero and the villain
And we can do the same exact thing here
let's just moveAll that down into that draw
Health function.
And I'll actually section this off to make
it a little cleaner so we'll say section
hero here
This guy be my section villainAwesome.
So the last thing we need to do here is do
our draw help
So whenever we call this attack function now
It's going to trigger that hero attack that
villain attack and then finally it's going
to draw the health of all those
And you can actually close them up over here
when you're kind of finished with that
function and you can
always reopen it as well so now the draw
should work correctly when I'm actually
clicking on the attack button
So I should see a showSo I should see the
hero's Health actually hit zero now.
Unless by some rare chance I win I don't
think so
So we got the oh no the Crusaders was slain
and we get that negative fiveSo let's fix
that really quick as well.
So we'll say ifSo right now even though it
is less than or equal to and it's hitting
that alert.
It's going to go to the negativeSo it's
actually just say hero health. Equals zero.
And we'll go ahead and do theAnd we'll go
ahead and do the same for our hero attack as
well.
So before I return that we'll make sure that
the villain Health hits zero and stays at
zero and we don't want to necessarily go
below zero
So let's see that inGo back to our web
application.
And we'll hit the attack again
So we get that oh no we lost but now we get
our heroes health is at zero
And at this point we can no longer attack
because we are defeated
Don't know why
Soon maybe it just isn't happening quick and
it's so slow
This is me you know I'm saying thatIf I hit
this now nope it's just too slow whatever
that's fine.
So right now in our web applicationThis
isn't very fun for the hero.
I don't really have any I can't even get
them below 80 Health at this point it's ooh
So ice isn't a great user experience cuz it
doesn't seem like you'd
have to be the luckiest guy ever to actually
beat him right now
So let's add in that a functionThat allows
me to drink a potion.
And be able to heal myself for a certain
amount
So before we do that let's actually create
that within our JavaScriptOr excuse me our
HTML.
So we already have our attack button here
So we'll just go ahead and create another
callWe will label this one potion.
We'll put the drink potion function on it
right now
And I want to show up right now this should
air whenever I hit this on click right now
Because that drink potion function is not
created in our JavaScript
Because right now we have nowhere that we're
drinking a potion so right now I can just
We'll just return no for nowWe actually can
click it. Actually it's not even do that.
Because we need to create that function
within our JavaScriptSo we'll say drink
potion.
And we can save thatNot from here it removes
that air.
So the idea when I drink my potion we can
have it
We essentially just want to increase our
hero health
We're going to just do 25 so whenever I
click that my hero Health should increase by
25So let's do the same thing that we did
here.
And draw that function up here
The biggest thing like the mistake we made
earlier is it's important of the order of
operation so I have the two attacks
No what am I talking aboutI'm high bro.
So now we made this function for drink
potion we can go back
And we can read so now we create the
functionality of the strength potion let's
go ahead and also add
No I'll do make the air on purposeSo now
this function is made for drink potion let's
go.
Show it off in our
Web application now that we create this
function for a drink potion let's go show
that off in a web application
So we know it's going to heal me for 25 so
let's try to hit 63 so when I drink potion
My health is still 63 but if I get it tag we
can notice that my health did indeed go up
so if I hit potion again
We can notice and we also go above hundred
so that's something we're going to want to
fix as well but that's because I draw
function
Is never happening we're never drawing our
healthSo the cool thing is we can actually
just call that function again.
Within our drink potion
And now every time I click that drink potion
it's going to call that Heroes health
But like I said there is a problem right now
cuz my Hero's Health can go above 100 and
I don't want that to happen I want it my
health to only be able to hit 100
So let's do the same thing that we did
earlier with our
With our feelings help in here if it goes
below zero we want to just set it back to
zero immediately so it never really hits
that negative
So let's say if our heroes health is greater
than 100I want you just a hard reset it to
100.
So now when I attack and I hit potion it's
actually only going to ever go to 100
cuz the second it goes above 100 it's going
to immediately just reset back down to 100
And technically there's like a super super
millisecond where it would be technically
but because it computers are so fast you can
never catch that instance
But the only problem now with this
applicationIs pretty much impossible to lose
now.
Because every time I help get slowSo let's
use that math random again to create some
variety.
And when you do the same thing with our
villain Health if you know Sarah as well it
actually went below zero
Let's fix that and we'll add a little bit of
Randomness to the potion as well
So let's go ahead and make a conditional
here as well so we'll say ifVillain health.
Is less than or equal to zero hereLet's just
make villain Health zero.
Awesome
So let's go test that out really quick and
make sure that's working the way we want it
to
Let's make sure I don't lose while testing
Oh it's closeOkay perfect and we did see
that the villains Health did hit zero.
And while we're at it let's go ahead and add
like a victory for when we actually defeat
the
VillainSo we'll do the same thing here we'll
go ahead and say at an alert as well.
So we'll reuse that our old friendly emoji
fromCode works.
Coffee Co will use the tadaAnd we'll say the
code works.
Crusader vanquishedThe coding virus.
And then we'll just say you wonAnd let's we
get that emoji the tada. Sweet.
Just a little extra touch when you actually
win
Great so let's go back to that drink potion
I'll be back